bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france une toute première
réaction pour commencer après cette
décision de la justice britannique
on avait un double sentiment le premier
dès lundi on était quand même on se
réjouissait de la décision évidemment de
ne pas extrader l'instant jean les états
unis ça c'était la premier le premier
sentiment en revanche on en a eu un
second et on a été assez assez inquiet
assez rapidement dans la mesure où on a
vu que le journalisme n'était pas du
tout lié à la décision de la juge et que
c'était surtout son état de santé et son
état de santé mentale depuis des mois où
l'on le signalant avec le docteur melzer
notamment le rapporteur spécial sur la
torture que l'état de santé de julian
assange a été très mauvais dans cette
prison et on n'a pas été surpris de sa
décision mais on a compris rapidement ce
n'était pas le journalisme qui était en
question ici est la preuve c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la décision de ne pas le
libérer va tout à fait donc dans le sens
de nos craintes
les etats-unis ont annoncé vouloir faire
appel de la décision de la justice
britannique concernant donc
l'extradition de julian assange quelle
est la probabilité la probabilité que
cela aboutisse selon vous la même que
pour la première instance c'est-à-dire
que tous très honnêtement on n'en sait
rien et tout et tout est encore possible
la justice dans nos pays et je l'espère
en tout cas libre d'agir et surtout de
d'or de regarder le droit dans le fond
ce le fond du sujet il est vraiment sur
la liberté d'information
et parce que forcément sur la question
de la santé d'un homme donc l'appel va
encore durer des semaines et des
semaines voire des encore des auditions
et cette décision de la justice anglaise
du jour montre tout simplement que ça va
être le statu quo encore pour le julian
assange est c'est la terrible la
nouvelle appli terry qui puisse arriver
pour pour ce pour ce pour ce confrère et
très honnêtement j'ai vraiment de gros
doutes sur la source sur son avenir
puisque il était déjà dans un état
psychologique désastreux et son père
john shipton me l'a signalé au courrier
récemment la la j'ai vraiment des
grandes craintes sur son état de santé
tout simplement sur la vie de juin songe
qu'il est passé cet homme n'a rien à
faire en prison
aujourd'hui vous avez le sentiment que
le dossier julian assange est devenu
essentiellement politique au détriment
de la démarche initiale qui se voulait
d'ordre journalistique c'est ce que vous
nous dites absolument ces procès du
journalisme c'est un procès politique
c'est le procès du droit connaître et et
là on touche le fond où une fois encore
sur cette question et julian assange
c'est le symbole de tous les
journalistes qui sont aujourd'hui en
prison
selon notre décompte une à 235 dans le
monde et ses symboles de tous ceux qui
ont envie de faire leur travail
correctement avec des règles éthiques
avec tout tout simplement le souci de la
qualité d'information est aujourd'hui
effectivement c'est un seul procès c'est
un procès politique contre assange mais
c'est le procès surtout du journalisme
de qualité et ça c'est moi j'ai des
vrais livres et questionnements le des
vraies craintes par rapport à la rapport
à la ligne g n a songé pour tirer
notamment pour espionnage aux états unis
pour la diffusion de centaines de
milliers de documents un convive
confidentielles
au vu de ce long dossier julian assange
avait des conséquences judiciaires est
ce qu'aujourd'hui une telle démarche
sera encore envisageable oui bien sûr on
essayait toujours de croire que faire
son travail correctement dans le monde
est possible
à san jose a montré qu'il était possible
d'aller d'aller d'alimenter des grands
consortiums et d'ailleurs il ya des
consortiums européens du consortium
mondiaux de journalisme d'investigation
qui font un travail extraordinaire et
typhons qui amène le journalisme un
coopératif le journalisme de qualité
vraiment dans un dans un dans un domaine
qui qui n'est pas toujours le cas il
faut l'admettre dans les médias dits
occidentaux donc je crois qu'il a montré
une voie il faut qu'on continue lui
qu'une voie de de cette investigation
qui devrait être celui du journalisme
mais on en a souvent affaire
malheureusement à des conditions de
travail dans les rédactions qui ne sont
pas à la hauteur de ce qu'on attendrait
donc qui permettait pas forcément
toujours aux journalistes de faire un
travail et tout ça et surtout d'apporter
une information
tous les citoyens sont en droit
d'attendre
l'australien est aujourd'hui souper par
un grand nombre d'organisations de
défense de la liberté de la presse 12
ans fait partie qu'elle soutient très
concrètement pour julian assange alors
jura sont chez particulier par rapport à
la fédération internationale puisqu'il
est membre de nos trafics et australiens
c'est qu'ils les membres de notre
organisation il est détenteur de carte
de presse internationale depuis
plusieurs années en tant que rédacteur
en chef de wikileaks
et donc nous on a toujours soutenu
d'autres piliers australien donc la nba
mais également non nos confrères et
consoeurs anglais la national union of
journaliste qui est aujourd'hui à
londres très très en pointe sur ce
dossier là donc nos campagnes ne
s'arrêteront pas évidemment aujourd'hui
et très honnêtement je n'avais des
craintes avant avant la décision du 4
janvier j'avais des craintes sur cette
libération et ces craintes sont
justifiées là une fois encore et et on
ne laissera pas faire et on va continuer
à mettre en oeuvre tout ce qui est en
notre pouvoir et notamment dans 9 hrs
dhainaut soutien et nos contacts au
niveau politique pour essayer d'arracher
cette cette libération et puis que de
faire en sorte que toutes les charges
soulever une fois de plus cet homme
comme les deux cent trente quatre autres
journalistes dans le monde cet homme a
en effet en prison merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation sur
arte france anthony bellanger secrétaire
général de la fédération internationale
des journalistes